Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Si je vous demandais aujourd’hui :
« Quelle est la situation de la démocratie
dans le monde ? »,
je suis à peu près sûr que
la plupart d’entre vous répondrait
que le diagnostic est sombre.
Et d’ailleurs, en 2022,
le magazine britannique « The Economist »,
qui publie chaque année
un indice de la démocratie,
en a conclu qu’en 2021,
la baisse de l’indice était la plus
importante depuis une vingtaine d’années.
Aujourd’hui, selon ce magazine,
47% des habitants de la planète
vivent dans une démocratie,
37% dans un régime autoritaire
et le reste dans un régime mixte.
Et de manière très significative,
le rapport de The Economist se conclut
par un chapitre consacré au défi chinois.
Pourquoi le défi chinois ?
Eh bien, parce que face aux prétentions
démocratiques de l’Occident,
la Chine oppose un modèle, où, dit-elle,
elle associe la prospérité et l’autorité.
Selon elle, l’Occident est en train
de montrer son inefficacité
avec la crise des subprimes en 2008,
avec sa gestion
plus ou moins bonne du Covid,
avec enfin les fantaisies de Donald Trump.
Alors que la Chine, elle, a prouvé
que son modèle fonctionnait.
Elle a pas mal d’arguments.
En 1980, à parité de pouvoir d’achat,
le PIB de la Chine était
le sixième du PIB des États-Unis.
Aujourd’hui, à parité de pouvoir d’achat,
le PIB de la Chine est de 12%
supérieur à celui des États-Unis.
On comprend donc que pour un certain
nombre de dictateurs du tiers-monde,
le message est un message plutôt bienvenu.
Au lieu des ingérences, des leçons
et des discours sentencieux de l’Occident,
la Chine est en train de leur dire :
« C’est bien que vous soyez autoritaire.
C’est d’ailleurs la manière la plus
rapide d’aller à la prospérité. »
Cette prospérité qui est quand même
le plus important dans un pays pauvre.
Donc dans le tiers-monde,
on voit le recul de la démocratie
au cours de la dernière décennie.
Mais le ver est aussi dans le fruit
des pays occidentaux
avec l’ascension des populismes
de gauche et de droite
qui remettent en cause
la démocratie libérale et l’État de droit.
Et avouons-le,
au moment de la crise du Covid,
les États démocratiques, en prenant
toute une série de mesures autoritaires,
n’ont pas donné quand même
la meilleure image de cette démocratie.
Est-ce que Joe Biden a raison ?
Est-ce que Joe Biden a raison
de nous dire :
« La démocratie est en danger,
nous devons faire un front des démocraties
face aux autocraties. » ?
Est-ce qu’il a raison
d’être à ce point alarmiste ?
Je pense que, pour le suivre,
nous avons besoin d’accepter deux
présupposés qui me semblent discutables.
Le premier présupposé,
c’est de penser que la marche
de l’autocratie vers la démocratie,
ou vice versa,
est une marche sans retour,
est une marche horizontale.
Et cette marche, nous devons,
nous les Occidentaux, l’aider,
et nous devons éviter
que des pays puissent reculer
dans cette marche vers la démocratie.
Deuxième présupposé,
c’est de penser qu’au fond,
les peuples ne comptent pas tellement.
C’est-à-dire que la démocratie, ce ne
sont pas les peuples qui vont l’imposer,
mais que ces peuples ont besoin
de l’aide de l’Occident.
Alors regardons ces deux présupposés,
si vous en êtes d’accord.
Premier présupposé :
cette sorte de marche verticale
ou horizontale, comme vous voulez,
vers la démocratie,
comme si la démocratie
était un long fleuve tranquille.
Regardons notre propre histoire.
Nous avons mis deux siècles
à devenir des démocraties
et il faut bien dire que ce long fleuve
tranquille n’a pas été tranquille.
Il y a eu des remous,
il y a eu des écueils.
Rappelons le coup d’État de Louis Napoléon
Bonaparte le 2 décembre 1851.
Rappelons l’État français
du maréchal Pétain.
À peu près toutes les démocraties sont
passées par ce genre de moments de crise.
Après tout, jusque dans les années 60,
aux États-Unis,
il était interdit dans 30 États
aux Blancs d’épouser des Noires,
ce qui n’est quand même pas
un exemple particulièrement démocratique.
Donc, nous, les Occidentaux, d’abord,
essayons de perdre
notre sentiment de supériorité.
Deuxièmement, c’est une façon de dire :
« Il y a une seule démocratie. »
La nôtre, naturellement.
Regardons déjà cette démocratie.
Est-ce qu’elle est unique ?
Les Américains considèrent par exemple
que l’Europe n’est pas démocratique
parce qu’elle limite
la liberté d’expression.
Comme vous le savez,
il est interdit en Europe,
dans la plupart des pays européens,
de nier l’Holocauste,
alors qu’aux États-Unis,
vous avez le droit.
Aux États-Unis, vous avez
des manifestations de Nazis
protégées par la police.
Les Américains diront aussi :
« L’Europe n’est pas démocratique.
On ne peut pas acheter
un fusil mitrailleur au supermarché. »
J'exagère un peu.
Et de notre côté, nous les Européens,
nous pouvons dire également,
en ce qui concerne les Américains,
que la liberté, la démocratie,
ce n’est pas seulement politique,
c’est aussi social,
et qu’un pays qui n’a pas de couverture
sociale pour toute sa population
n’est pas vraiment un pays démocratique.
Donc on voit déjà
que cette notion de démocratie,
d’abord, c'est un processus.
Ça donne des résultats
qui peuvent être divers.
Et enfin, pour essayer
de nous appeler à la modestie,
ce qui n’est pas
une des caractéristiques de l’Occident,
selon le rapport de The Economist,
sur ces 47% de la population
de la planète
qui vivent dans des États démocratiques,
6% seulement vivent
dans des démocraties parfaites
et 41% dans des démocraties imparfaites.
Et naturellement, la France fait partie
de la deuxième catégorie.
Donc essayons de relativiser
cette démarche démocratique.
Elle est diverse,
elle peut avoir des arrêts,
voire des marches arrière.
Et d’ailleurs, quand on y réfléchit,
pour poursuivre un peu ce débat
sur la définition de la démocratie,
vous vous rendez bien compte
qu’en général, lorsqu’on pense démocratie,
on pense élections.
Et lorsque les Américains
ont envahi l’Irak en 2003,
aussitôt, on a organisé des élections.
Et évidemment, l’Irak n’est pas
devenu une démocratie.
Parce que la démocratie,
ce n’est pas seulement de voter.
La démocratie,
c’est aussi une presse active,
c’est une société civile avec des
organisations, avec des partis politiques.
Et c'est aussi le sentiment que la
tolérance fait partie de la vie politique.
Et ce n'est pas du jour au lendemain
qu'on acquiert cet ensemble.
Donc là aussi, donnons du temps au temps,
essayons de voir dans la temporalité
et non pas à l’instant T
où nous pourrions évidemment désespérer.
Mais il y a aussi un deuxième présupposé
dans cette volonté
de faire un front de l’Occident,
des démocraties contre l’autocratie,
c’est d’oublier tout bêtement
le rôle des opinions publiques,
le rôle des peuples.
Regardez par exemple la Chine.
Évidemment, avec ce qui d’ailleurs
parfois frôle un peu le racisme,
on considère que les Chinois sont
une sorte de masse amorphe
qui est subordonnée
à un État tout-puissant,
avec des contrôles,
des surveillances, extrêmement efficaces.
Mais ce n’est pas vrai,
ce n’est simplement pas vrai.
En réalité, en Chine, tous les jours,
il y a des dizaines d’émeutes,
de troubles, des troubles locaux
contre la corruption, contre la pollution,
contre des décisions de dirigeants
qui sont contestés.
Les Chinois ne sont pas une masse amorphe.
Et on le voit d’ailleurs
de manière spectaculaire
en ce qui concerne
la politique du zéro Covid.
Vous vous rappelez cette politique.
Elle consistait, dès que l’on constatait
deux ou trois cas positifs,
fondamentalement, à fermer la ville.
Quand on parle de ville chinoise,
ça peut être 10, 12 millions d’habitants.
Donc tout le monde devenait
prisonnier de son appartement.
Et les malheureux cas positifs,
eux, étaient internés,
dans des conditions
souvent extrêmement difficiles.
Il se trouve que,
lorsqu’on allait en Chine,
on était soumis aussi à cette quarantaine.
J’en parlais à notre ambassadeur à Pékin
qui me racontait trois semaines passées
dans un hôtel absolument sordide
dont il est sorti malade
tellement c’était dur.
Vous voyez, pas de différence
entre les ambassadeurs et les hôtes,
contrairement à ce que beaucoup pensent.
Donc, vous aviez cette politique
qui était suivie depuis trois ans.
Peu à peu, les Chinois ont commencé
à dire : « On en a assez. »
Donc on a vu des émeutes, on a vu
des incidents dans l’ensemble du pays
et peu à peu, ces mouvements qui étaient
une série de mouvements locaux,
ont convergé et sont devenus
une véritable protestation nationale.
Et, le pire du pire
pour le Parti communiste chinois,
cette protestation a commencé
à crier des slogans contre le régime.
Eh bien, dans les 24 heures,
dans les 24 heures,
le pouvoir chinois renonçait du jour
au lendemain à la politique du zéro Covid.
Je crois qu’on n’a pas assez souligné
le caractère spectaculaire
de la volte-face du gouvernement chinois.
Ce n’était pas parce que, d’un seul coup,
des scientifiques avaient dit
au pouvoir chinois :
« Mais non, ça ne marche pas votre truc !
Il faut changer de politique,
c’est trop coûteux. »
C’était tout simplement parce que
le peuple chinois n’en voulait plus.
Eh bien, le régime a reculé.
D’ailleurs, on parle souvent, vous savez,
que le régime chinois
est un régime qui se durcit.
Ce qui est le cas, il faut bien le dire.
Il y a beaucoup moins aujourd’hui
de liberté de parole.
Il y a aujourd’hui
beaucoup moins de discussions
qu’il y en avait il y a dix ans,
lorsqu’on allait en Chine.
Mais vous savez, lorsqu'un régime se
durcit, ce n'est pas une preuve de force,
c’est plutôt une preuve de faiblesse.
Deuxième exemple de cette vitalité des
sociétés civiles, c'est évidemment l'Iran.
En Iran, je dirais - même les diplomates
peuvent avoir des sentiments.
C’est quand même bouleversant
de voir ce peuple iranien,
de voir ces femmes
et cet ensemble du peuple iranien
qui protestent inlassablement depuis
maintenant des mois contre le régime.
Un régime qui tire, un régime qui pend,
un régime qui arrête massivement,
un régime qui réprime.
Vous voyez bien, les Iraniens,
ils ne sont aidés par personne.
Il n'y a aucune ingérence extérieure.
Eh bien, imperturbablement,
ils continuent,
ils continuent de protester.
Et il est évident que
le régime en est donc ébranlé.
Et je ne peux pas éviter
non plus un paradoxe.
Mais essayons de nous tourner vers la
protestation populiste dans nos sociétés.
Au fond, que nous disent ces populistes,
cette opinion publique,
et éventuellement les hommes politiques
qui en sont les porte-parole ?
Ils nous disent d’abord :
« Nous n’en voulons plus, des experts.
Ni du gouvernement des experts.
Nous ne voulons plus de ces banques
centrales totalement irresponsables
qui prennent des décisions capitales
pour notre économie, pour notre vie.
Nous ne voulons plus
de ces autorités que l’on crée
et qui sont constituées
de hauts fonctionnaires
qui peuvent prendre
eux aussi des décisions
qui échappent au contrôle du Parlement.
Nous ne voulons plus de ces juges
qui disent que le Parlement a
le droit ou pas le droit de faire,
alors que le Parlement, c’est l’émanation
de la souveraineté nationale. »
D’une certaine manière, reconnaissons-le,
ce populisme, c’est aussi
une revendication de démocratie.
D’une certaine manière,
ce populisme, c’est aussi la preuve
que, même dans ses franges extrêmes,
cette opinion publique se réclame
de la démocratie.
Et donc, si aujourd’hui,
loin du monde politique,
les Chinois dans leurs rues, les Iraniens
ou même un certain nombre de nos électeurs
crient « Toujours plus de démocratie »,
même si nous n’approuvons pas
certaines de ces revendications,
il faut bien reconnaître
que la démocratie reste l’espoir,
reste le rêve des opinions publiques.
Il n’y a aucune opinion publique
qui rêve d’autocratie,
de dictature, de régime autoritaire.
Elle s’y résigne éventuellement,
mais elle n’en rêve pas.
La démocratie, ça reste
l’horizon de l’humanité.
Alors nous les Occidentaux,
que devons-nous faire ?
D’abord, comme je l’ai dit,
le plus difficile pour les Occidentaux,
c’est la modestie.
Donc c’est de comprendre qu’après tout,
nous avons eu deux siècles d’avance
sur la plupart de ces pays
et que c’est eu un peu
le hasard, le hasard de l’Histoire,
et que nous n’avons aucun droit
de prendre les autres pays de haut,
ou de vouloir leur faire la leçon.
Et d’autant moins
en voulant exporter
notre type de démocratie.
Comme je l’ai dit, il y a des types
de démocraties différents.
Il y a des nuances dans la démocratie.
La manière dont le peuple peut
exprimer son pouvoir peut varier.
Elle varie après tout.
Regardez les États-Unis,
ou la Grande-Bretagne d’ailleurs,
sont capables d’élire un chef d’État
ou d’élire un Premier ministre
avec une minorité de voix.
Donald Trump a été élu
avec 3 millions de voix [en moins].
Un Premier ministre britannique en général
n’a jamais la majorité des suffrages,
n’a jamais 50% des suffrages.
Pour nous, Français,
ça peut être choquant.
Les Britanniques, les Américains,
considèrent que c’est normal.
Il y a donc des types de démocraties.
Nous n’avons pas de leçon à [donner]
et nous devons faire confiance aussi
à ces opinions publiques.
Devons-nous rester passifs pour autant ?
Je ne le pense pas.
Je crois que nous devons aider,
sans ingérence,
ces sociétés civiles qui essaient
de lutter pour leur libération.
Un milliardaire américain, Turner,
a donné 100 millionsde dollars
à une ONG américaine,
Human Rights Watch,
et le directeur de l’ONG me demandait :
« Mais d’après vous, qu’est-ce qu’on doit
faire de ces 100 millionsde dollars ? »
Je lui avais dit : « Vous ne devez
surtout pas les dépenser en Occident.
Vous devez les dépenser dans les pays
qui sont en voie de démocratisation.
Vous devez aider les ONG,
les associations, leur donner les moyens,
car c’est à elles de lutter
pour leur propre avenir. »
Donc ayons confiance,
donnons du temps au temps.
Et n’oublions surtout pas
que l’engagement pour la démocratie
n’est pas une invention occidentale.
Nous n’avons pas en être fiers,
ça correspond profondément
à l’aspiration de toutes les sociétés.
En tout cas, de toutes
les sociétés que je connais.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)